[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من رام الله في
الضفه الغربيه على وقع تصعيد اسرائيلي
كانت احدث حلقاته اليوم باغتيال الاحتلال
ثلاثه فلسطينيين قرب بلده عرابه في جنين
جنوبيه الضفه الى نيام عاصمه النيجر التي
تعيش حاله الترقب مع انتهاء مهله مجموعه
اكواس لقاده الانقلاب للتراجع عن خطواتهم
بينما احتشد انصار قاده الانقلاب للتنديد
بالعقوبات الاخيره والى ام درمان احدى مدن
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مع تصعيد سلاح
الجو بالجيش السوداني غاراته على مواقع
الدعم السريع
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
وسط تصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه
الاحتلال يغتال ثلاثه فلسطينيين قرب بلده
عرابه جنوبيه جنين بزعم توجههم لتنفيذ
عمليه ضد اسرائيليين حماس تشدد على ضروره
صياغه خطه وطنيه لمواجهه الاحتلال وحركه
الجهاد تعتبر الهجوم عدوانا على كل
الفلسطينيين وتتوعد برد قوي للمقاومه
دفعه واحده
مع انتهاء مهله اكواس لعوده النظام
الحاكمي في النيجر
قاده الانقلاب يحشدون مؤيديهم في العاصمه
النيامي ويشددون على الا تراجع عن مسار
التغيير وطي صفحه الرئيس المحتز
[موسيقى]
في يوم من التصعيد الميداني المتبادل
روسيا تشن هجوما واسعا النطاق تقول انه
استهدف قواعد جويه في غرب اوكرانيا والجيش
الاوكراني يشن هجمات على جسرين في شبه
جزيره القرم وخرسون جنوبا
في تكثيف لهجمات الجيش السوداني سلاح الجو
يشل غارات على مواقع للدعم السريع في
الخرطوم بحري ويستهدف القصر الجمهوري
والدعم السريع يقول ان قواته ما زالت
تحاسب القياده العامه للجيش في مبنى
المخابرات في الخرط
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد ناقشنا على
منصاتنا الرقميه السيناريوهات المحتمله
للتطورات في النيجر مع نهايه المهله التي
حددتها المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا اكواس لاطلاق سراح الرئيس المحتجز
محمد بازوم والتراجع عن الانقلاب
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي ابرز
سيناريوهات المحتمله لانهاء الازمه في
النيجر اما الاجابه فهي على النحو الاتي
27% رجحوا سيناريو استمرار الوضع القائم
بينما صوت نحو 34% لصالح سيناريو تصعيد
والتدخل العسكري واخيرا قال نحو 39% انهم
مع خيار تسويه وصيغه دبلوماسيه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بتفاصيل غير مسبوقه صوره جديده لتلسكوب
جيمس ويب تلقي مزيد من الضوء على دوره
حياه النجوم
نبدا من فلسطين اذ قتلت قوات الاحتلال
ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين قرب بلده عرابه في
جنين جنوبيه الضفه الغربيه بيان مشترك
لجيش الاحتلال وقوات حرس الحدود والشباك
قال ان اطلاق النار استهدف مركبه كان
يستقلها شبان الثلاثه وانهم كانوا في
طريقهم لتنفيذ العمليه
وقد نعت كتيبه جنين الشبان الفلسطينيين
الثلاثه الذين اقتلتهم قوات الاحتلال
اليوم في عرابه قرب جنين ووصفت الكتيبه
التابعه لسرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي في بيان لها
الاغتيال بانه اغتيال جبان متوعده بالثار
المكان عرابه جنوبيه جنين شماليه الضفه
الغربيه قوه من جيش الاحتلال تنفذ عمليه
تستهدف سياره يستقلها شبان فلسطينيون
الروايه الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن نشاط مشترك
بين الشباب والشرطه برصد سياره خرجت من
مخيم جنين فبادرت القوه الى اطلاق النار
على السياره وقتلت من في داخلها بذريعه
توجههم لتنفيذ عمليه وبحسب بيان جيش
الاحتلال فان المستهدف ونايف ابو سويس مع
شخصين اخرين وقال البيان ان ابو سويس
متورط في نشاطات عسكريه بتوجيهات من جهات
في قطاع غزه وفي اول رد فعل فلسطيني وصف
الناطق باسم حركه حماس العمليه بالجريمه
الجديده وقال بيان للحركه ان الاحتلال
سيدفع ثمن جرائمه وان الشعب الفلسطيني
ومقاومته لن يمررها جرائم العدوان دون ان
يدفع الثمن
ووصفت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي العمليه بانها
جريمه مكتمله الاركان بينما قال متحدث
باسم الحركه ان عمليات المقاومه ستتصاعد
امام ما وصفه بالعدوان الممنهج مشيرا الى
تنسيق بين اذرع المقاومه في الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
ينضم لنا من رام الله مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
ومن نابلس نواف العامر الباحث والمحلل
السياسي اهلا وسهلا بكم الدكتور مصطفى هل
نحن عمامه مرحله جديده من التصعيد
بالتاكيد الذي شهدناه خلال 24 ساعه
الاخيره
سلسله من الجرائم في اطار حرب ارهابيه
فاشيه يشنها ليس فقط جيش الاحتلال بل
المستعمرين المستوطنين ايضا جريمه اغتيال
الشهداء الثلاثه الاغتيال الميداني الذي
جرى في عرابه جنين بالاضافه الى جريمه
اغتيال الشاب قصي معطان بن بلده برقه ومن
قبل مستوطن يعمل مع بن جرير
وايضا جريمه دهس مستوطن لطفل عمره اربع
سنوات الطفل جبريل سواركه في منطقه بيت
لحم هذه حرب دمويه يشنها الارهابيون
المستوطنون وجيش الاحتلال ونتيجتها حتى
هذه اللحظه 218 شهيد منذ بدايه هذا العام
منهم 37 طفل اصغرهم عمره عامين ونصف محمد
التميمي في النبي صالح
هذه الحرب الدمويه لا يمكن الا ان تقابل
بمقاومه فلسطينيه طبعا وبالتالي الامور
تسير نحو تصعيد شديد لانه لا الشعب
الفلسطيني ولا الشباب الفلسطيني ولا
المقاومه الفلسطينيه يمكن ان يقبلوا
بالسكوت على هذه الجرائم الوحشيه
والارهابيه بما في ذلك الاعدام الميداني
البشعه الذي جرى اليوم لثلاثه شبان في
جنين وبالتالي طبعا هناك تصعيد خطير
المسؤول عنه الاحتلال والمسؤول عنه هذه
الحكومه الفاشيه الاسرائيليه والمسؤول عنه
المجتمع الدولي الذي يواصل الصمت على هذه
الجرائم ضد الشعب الفلسطيني ما هي خيارات
المقاومه في هذه المرحله سيد نواف العامل
اسعد الله اوقاتكم واضح ان المقاومه
الفلسطيني كما اعلنت اليوم يعني انها لن
تقف مكتوفه ليدي وانها ان الاحتلال سيدفع
الثمن المقاومه الان امام خيار يعني
يمنحها المزيد من الشرعيه لمواجهه
الاحتلال ومقاومه الاحتلال وعندما اعلن
الاحتلال اليوم انه يعني
قصد خليه كانت تتوجه الى تنفيذ عمليه في
احدى المعسكر المستوطنات الاسرائيليه فهذا
يعني ان صحت مزاعمه ان المقاومه في جنين
وفي الضفه الغربيه
ترفض ان تبقى يعني مقيده في جغرافيه معينه
لان الخطه العسكريه المعده والامنيه لمخيم
جنين والمقاومه في الضفه الغربيه ان تظل
حبيسه الجغرافيا
عندما يريدون ان يقصوا ويكلموا اظافر
المحيط مخيم جنين والمدينه فانهم بذلك
يخشون الحضور والقوه التي يمثلها مخيم
جنين عندما تحولت الى قاعده للمقاومه فهي
التي توجه اليها عبد الفتاح خروشي منفذ
حواره وتوجه اليها في الطريق خالد صباح
منفذ عينيه وتوجه اليها الشهيد الامس كامل
ابو بكر من عن الرمانه ودخل الى قلب تل
ابيب اذا المقاومه يعني ليست نائمه وليست
يعني في حاله طرف وعندما نشاهد فعل
المقاومه وفعل من ينفذ نرى ان الجيل الذي
يعني هو القوه الضاربه للمقاومه هو جيل
شباب لا يعرف الموت لا يخاف لا يحسب حساب
للقوى يعني عندما يكون القائد المجموعه
التي تم اغتيال عمره 26 وهو يقود يعني
جناح عسكري فهذا يدلل على ان الشعب
الفلسطيني هو شعب ولاد وان المقاومه لا
تنكسر
دكتور مصطفى كيف ينعكس ما يحدث على وحده
الصف الفلسطيني وهل هناك بالفعل حقيقه
شواهد على ذلك
هناك وحده صف فلسطيني على صعيد المقاومه
هناك وحده صف ميدانيه يصنعها هؤلاء
المقاومون والابطال الذين فعلا يتجاوزوا
انقسامات فصائلهم ليصنعوا وحده نضاليه
وكفاحيه على الارض ولكن على المستوى
القيادي للاسف ما زال الانقسام قائما
والاجتماعات التي جرت في مصر للاسف لم
تؤدي الى اي نتيجه على الاطلاق وما زلنا
نشهد ظواهر سلبيه مثل الحديث عن
استمرار تنسيق امني مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
واستمرار وجود اعتقالات سياسيه وهذا طبعا
يضعف وحده الصف الفلسطيني الامر الجوهري
الذي نعيشه اليوم هو انه الاحتلال اغلق كل
الابواب ولا يوجد سوى باب واحد امام الشعب
الفلسطيني هو المقاومه والكفاح وتبني
استراتيجيه وطنيه كفاحيه موحده ومقاومه
ومقاومه للتصدي للخطر الذي يتعرض له كل
بيت فلسطيني كل طفل فلسطيني هؤلاء
المجرمون في حكومه الاحتلال الفاشيه
يستهدفون الشعب الفلسطيني باسره ولذلك ما
زالت القيادات برايي الفلسطينيه متخلفه عن
مستوى الوحده النضاليه والميدانيه التي
يصنعها هؤلاء المناضلون على الارض وعليها
ان ترتقي الى مستوى هذه الوحده اليوم نحن
بامس الحاجه الى الوحده ولكن ليس على اي
شيء على استراتيجيه وطنيه كفاحيه مقاومه
لانه لا يوجد بديل اخر مع احتلال لا يفهم
الى لغه القوه ومع اجرام فاشي ارهابي لا
يفهم ولن يستوعب الا ان يكون الشعب
الفلسطيني مناظلا ضد اجرامه وضد ما يقوم
به سيدنا نواف العامر كيف يراقب
الفلسطينيون ما يحدث بين الاسرائيليين
انفسهم انشد وجذب وربما الانقسام لم ليس
مسبوقا على هذا النحو من قبل على الاقل
على العلم في ظل ما نتحدث منه من تصعيد مع
الجانب الفلسطيني
الفلسطيني كما يملك قوه المقاومه هو يملك
قوه الادراك ودراسه الحاله التي يعيشها
الاسرائيلي حاله الانقسام صحيح لكنه يدرك
في ذاقه الوقت ان الاسرائيلي اليمين
واليساري الحكومه والمعارضه حتى قوه
السلام الاسرائيليه عندما تكون الحرب
عندما يكون هناك استدعاء كلهم يحملون سلاح
لمواجهه الفلسطيني الفلسطيني يدرك ايضا في
ذات السيف في ذات السياق وفي الحاله
المعاشه حاليا ان الاغتيالات التي ينفذها
الاحتلال ويجمع عليها اقطاب السياسه
والاحزاب الاسرائيليه كافه في استهداف
الدم الفلسطيني يدركون كما يدرك الفلسطيني
ان الاغتيالات والاستهداف بالقتل لن يمنح
الاحتلال الامن ولن يمنحوا شرعية هذا
الاحتلال الذي يحاول بشكل او باخر ان يثبت
الانقسام العميق في الساحه الفلسطينيه
ويحدث شرخ هائل عندما يقدم اغراءات سياسيه
السلطه عقب الانعقاد الكبينه هذا المساء
عندما الجو قرر تجويد الديون الفلسطينيه
للسلطه لمده عام وقررت توسيع معبر اللمبي
وقرر يعني الترويج لمنطقه صناعيه في منطقه
ترقيوبيا في منطقه الخليل جنوب الضفه
الغربيه لذلك الكل الاسرائيلي يجمع يعني
بفصائده وتوجهاته واحزابه وكي نوته على
استهداف الفلسطيني لم نسمع اي صوت اسرائيل
يتحدث عن رفضهم لدعوات دعوات القتل التي
اطلقها بن جفير اليوم عندما طالب بمنح
القاتل في قريه برقه الاوسمه والتبريئاتهم
من جرائم القتل لذلك الفلسطيني يعني عنده
ادراك وعنده حس ومسؤوليه تمكنه من استكمال
طريقه ومعرفه يعني الدهاليز السياسيه
التي تم يعني
التخطيط لها شكرا جزيلا من نابلس نواف
العامر الباحث والمحل السياسي ومن رام
الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوث الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
انطلقت في مدينه تل ابيب في هذه الاثناء
مسيره تحت عنوان الجنازه مسيره الاموات
وذلك للتنديد بتفشي الجريمه والعنف في
المدن والبلدات الفلسطينيه داخل اسرائيل
ومطالبه الحكومه الاسرائيليه بتعزيز الامن
في المدن العربيه ياتي ذلك في وقت تجاوز
فيه عدد ضحايا العنف في الوسط العربي 140
قتيلا هذا العام وهي حصيله غير مسبوقه
وقد شاركت في المسيره مؤسسات الجماهيريه
ومدنيه عربيه مختلفه اضافه الى جمعيات
حقوقيه اسرائيليه
هنا وسط مدينه تل ابيب انطلقت هذه المسيره
للتنديد بازدياد وتفشي جرائم القتل واعمال
العنف في البلدات والمدن الفلسطينيه داخل
الخط الاخضر هذه المسيره الصامته انطلقت
تحت عنوان الجنازه او مسيره الاموات
ويشارك فيها اهالي الضحايا واجهات شعبيه
وجماهيريه ومدنيه ومؤسسات حقوقيه
مختلفه المشاركون يحملون هذه التوابيت
بعدد الضحايا وقد بلغ عددهم منذ مطلع هذا
العام اكثر من 140
قتيلا ما يعادل ثلاثه اضعاف
القتلى في جرائم العنف مقارنه مع الفتره
ذاتها من العام الماضي وهي حصيله غير
مسبوقه مقارنه مع سنوات سابقه وفقا
لتوثيق من عده جمعيات
ومؤسسات تعمل داخل الخط الاخضر على كل
تابوت كما تشاهدون كتبت عباره عن القتيل
او هو وكانه يتحدث عن نفسه يتحدث عن قتله
المشاركون يطالبون الحكومه والسلطات
الاسرائيليه بالتدخل
الفوري والقيام بواجبها ومحاربه عصابات
الاجرام القياده الفلسطينيه داخل الخطا
الاخضر تحمل السلطات الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه
تفشي جرائم القتل واعمال العنف وتتهم
السلطات الاسرائيليه بالتقاعس بل وبحمايه
عائلات الاجرام نجوان سمري الجزيره تل
ابيب
[موسيقى]
والى النيجر حيث يستمر الترقب على حاله مع
انتهاء مهله مجموعه اكواس لقاده الانقلاب
للتراجع عن خطواتهم هذه المهله يفترض ان
تنتهي خلال السويعات قليله مصدر عسكري
مصدر عسكري في في نيامي قال للجزيره ان
الجيش لن يتراجع عن خطواته في تعليق
الدستور والاطاحه بالرئيس محمد بزومة وكما
تشاهدون الان على شاشتنا
فان المجلس العسكري في النيجر يقول ان
دوله اجنبيه عظمى تعد لعدوان على بلدنا
هذا في الوقت الذي اعلن فيه المجلس
العسكري اغلاق المجال الجوي في النيجر
وهذا كما ذكرنا يتزامن مع قرب انتهاء
المهله التي حددتها دول غرب افريقيا
الاقتصاديه
ليعود المسار الديمقراطيه في نيامي وهو ما
رفض قاده المجلس
العسكري ان يقوموا به تماما وقالوا ان
الرئيس محمد بازوم لن يعود الى السلطه في
الوقت الذي صوت فيه مجلس الشيوخ في
البرلمان النيجيري ونيجيريا هي القوه
الاكبر في دول اكواس صوت لصالح المسار
الدبلوماسي ولصالح تفادي اي مسار عسكري
هذا في الوقت الذي تتباين فيه مواقف الدول
المجاوره والتي سوف ناتي على ذكرها الان
عموما
للمزيد ينضم الينا من عاصمه النيجر نامي
حبيب بوري الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي
ولنبدا من الاخبار العاجله التي ذكرناها
سيد حبيب ما الذي يمكن ان نفهمه من هذه
التصريحات ان دوله اجنبيه عظمى تهدد او
تعد لعدوان على النيجر من الدوله المقصوده
من خلال حديث المجلس العسكري
اولا اشكرك واشكر جميع المشاهدين
والمتابعين لقناه الجزيره يعني فيما يتعلق
بالتدخل العسكري حقيقه هذا السيناريو
يعني هنا محليا عدد كبير من المواطنين
يستبعدون هذا التدخل لاسباب كثيره رغم ان
هناك ضغوطات وتصريحات من الدوليه
والاقليميه لماذا تسمعني
نعم نعم هل تسمعني سيد حميد
نعم تفضل تفضل اكمل نعم اسمعك جيدا نعم
لعده
نعم قلت لعده اسباب التدخل العسكري مستبعد
لاولا
الرئيس محمد بازون بيد الانقلابيين ومعه
حزمه
وكثيرون يستبعدون التدخل العسكري ولكن انا
احدثك عن تصريح للمجلس العسكري في النيجر
الان الذي يقول ان دوله اجنبيه عظمى كما
وصفها تعد لعدوان على بلدنا فما الذي يعني
هذا التصريح
نعم حقيقه انا هذا اعتبره انه ربما من
المبالغات التي تاتي من هنا وهنا ربما مع
المجلس العسكري يريد ان يشير بذلك بان
يعني ممكن هناك احتمال للتدخل العسكري
ولكن مع ذلك اعتقد هنا المجلس العسكري
يقصد
بالدوله يقصد
دوله فرنسا ولكن لا اعتقد بان المجلس يعني
بان المجلس يؤمن بان هذه الدوله الاجنبيه
يعني حقيقه تستعد بمعنى الكلمه للتدخل
العسكري مباشره فيما جرى في النيجر فربما
عدا من المبالغات التي تاتي من هنا وهنا
كما يعني قلته سابقا
شكرا جزيلا لك من يمي عاصمه النيجر حبيب
بوريا الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي وينضم
الينا من العاصمه النيجيريا نيامي مراسم
الجزيره فضل عبد الرزاق اذا فضل حاله ترقب
وقد اقتربت يعني اقترب وقت انتهاء المهله
التي حددها
الدول حدثتها دول الاكواس دول الغرب
افريقيا الاقتصاديه
نعم في الواقع عده بيانات
نشرها المجلس العسكري قبل لحظات وهي ثلاث
بيانات تتحدث عن ان دوله اجنبيه عظمى هكذا
تحدث البيان تجهز للعدوان على النيجر كما
قال البيان ايضا انه المجلس العسكري يدهو
كل الشباب في النيجر التجهيز للمشاركه في
الدفاع عن بلدهم بالاضافه الى ان المجلس
العسكري اعلن بانه يجري اغلاق المجال
الجوي
للنيجر كذلك تحدث بيان المجلس العسكري بان
بالرغم من الحديث الذي يدور ان انه
التدخل على عسكري تم التعبير عن رفضه من
معظم
النيجريين واظهروا ذلك في كثير من
المناسبات لكن
دولتين هكذا اشار البيان من خارج المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لغرب افريقيا بل وحدد ان هذين
الدولتين هما في وسط افريقيا تم على الاقل
بحسب بيان المجلس العسكر العسكري تم تجهيز
قوه في هذه البلدان من اجل الاعداد
للعدوان على النيجر كانت بيانات في القيت
في التلفزيون الحكومي وتحدثت عن كل هذه
التفاصيل التي تشير الى ان المجلس العسكري
يترقب ان يكون هناك تلا عسكريا من الجهات
التي تحدثت عن ها رافضه
للقرارات والخطوات التي اتخذها قاده الجيش
بعض قاده الجيش بالاطاعه بالرئيس محمد
بازوم وتعطيل الدستور وحل المؤسسات
الرسميه في النيجر من عاصمه النيجر
مراسل الجزيره فضل عبد الرزاق شكرا جزيلا
لك
اخادع هذا الهدوء لا تحسن النيجر مدارات
الخشيه والقلق هو قلق مما يقبل عليه البلد
الحابيس جغرافيا بغرب افريقيا في عهد
حكامه الجدد في الاقليم يحظى المجلس بدعم
دولتين حاله الانقلاب المجاورتين مالي
وبوركينا فاسو لكنه يواجه ضغوطا خارجيه
لترك السلطه بعد الاستيلاء عليها في
السادس والعشرين من يوليو الماضي واضح ان
الضغط الاشد ياتي من المجموعه الاقتصاديه
للدول غرب افريقيا اكواس
الهيئه نقلت الملف من طاوله الرؤساء الى
ايدي قاده اركان جيوشها فقد وضعوا بالفعل
خطه لتدخل عسكري محتمل هناك تشمل كيفيه
نشر القوات وتوقيته اهوى الصدام المحتوم
اذا رئيس الوزراء في حكومه رئيس النيجر
المحتز قال للجزيره ان هناك املا في
الوصول الى حل تفاضي نعم يمكن ان يكون
مشكله ذلك لكل المنطقه ولكن الامر كله
سيعتمد على طبيعه التدخل هذا وبهذا الصدد
نحن نستطيع ان نثق
بالخبراء العسكريين ضمن مجموعه الاكواس
الذي يكون حاليا بوضع مفهوم خطه هذا
التدخل الذي توقعنا حصوله في حاله نفطر
الى القيام به حتى نيجيريا التي تراس
مجموعه ريكوس صوت مجلس شيوخها لصالح حل
دبلوماسي في النيجر العمل بالقوه في
الدائره الاوسع يدعم الاتحاد الاوروبي
مجموعه اكواس ويدعو الى العوده الفوريه
للنظام الدستوري في النيجر لكنه يشارك
الجزائر كما قال الرغبه في تجنب التصعيد
هناك لما قد يكون له من عواقب واخيمه على
المنطقه
وفي منطقه الساحل بدا ان نيجر اضحى اخر
رهان للقوه الغربيه
الولايات المتحده ترى في النيجر رقعه
اساسيه من دائره قوتها الافريقيه
اما فرنسا فترى ان المحاوله الانقلابيه في
النيجر كما تسميها ادت الى اضعاف جهود
مكافحه الارهاب في المنطقه
وتؤكد ان وجودها العسكريه في النيجر يعود
الى ان السلطات الشرعيه هناك طلبت مساعده
باريس في مكافحه الارهاب
يعتقد محللون ان تلك القوات التي طردت
قبلا من مالي وبوركينا فاسو يمكن ان تكون
عنصر ارتكاز في مواجهه انقلابي النيجر
فهؤلاء لا يبدون اي نيه للعدول عن خطواتهم
بتعليق الدستور والاطاحه بالرئيس المنتخب
من دوسلدو في المانيا ينضم لنا ادمه مدير
الاتصال السابق في المجموعه الاقتصاديه
لدول غرب افريقيا اكوا السيد ادم اهلا بك
ستنتهي المهله خلال ساعتين او الثلاثه
المقبله منتصف الليل بتوقيت النيجر ما
الذي ستفعله دول
الاكواس بالضبط بعد انتهاء هذه المهله
من الصعب التنبؤ بدايه لا نعرف اذا ما كان
هنالك تدخل بدون ترخيص الامم المتحده اذ
انها لديها تفويض بترخيص التدخل العسكري
في مثل هذا الموقف شيء اخر اسمعه هنا في
السنغال وهي مركز للتدخل العسكريه حيث
قواتها في عام 18 كان هنالك
تدخل مع القوات البريطانيه في
الارجنتين اعرفوا ان هنالك طائرات من
النيتو
هذا ما تم
نشره في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي علينا ان
نتذكر انه في عام 2011
تدخلت بطلب الرئيس الفرنسي
وايضا
لاطاحه رئيس الوزراء كاميرا بالاط رئيسي
وقائد ليبيا في ذلك الوقت معمر القذافي
بالتالي هنالك طائرات تم
رصدها في مطاردك هل سيتم استخدامها من اجل
تسهيل نقل القوات والمعدات الى النيجر
لاننا نعرف ان معظم الدول التي تعهدت بان
تكون جزءا من التدخل العسكري مثل السنغال
وساحل الالعاب هم لا يمتلكون المعدات
التدخل وانا اتذكر عندما كنت خلال عملي في
الكواز وبعد ذلك انا اتذكر انه كان هنالك
تدخل
للدول الاكوانسه في
السنغال بيساوي ولكنهم اجبروا على طلب
الدعم الجوي من القوات النيجيريه وانا كنت
من قدم الطلب للرئيس من اجل
هذه الامور سيد ادم سيد ادم ما هي
ما هي التعقيدات التي
تلف
احتمال التدخل العسكري مع العلم ان عدد من
الدول المجاوره ترفض ذلك نذكر منها تشاد
ومالي وبوركينا فاسو
والجزائر وحتى انه مجلس الشيوخ في نيجيريا
الدوله الاكبر ايضا صوت لصالح المسار
التفاوضي او الدبلوماسي
نعم نعم العديد من الاطراف
تعترض وترفض هذه هذا التدخل الكثير من
الدول قالت كلا للتدخل العسكري لا نرى اي
احد حقا في دول غرب افريقيا او شعوبها
يدعم الكواز في هذا القرار الذي اتخذوه
بالتالي هذا الامر يمثل مشكله حقيقه لانه
حتى الدول السبعه خلال الاتحاد النيجيري
نعرف ان هنالك
رفضوا هذا الامر هنالك خطر ايضا من مساله
كسر وقطع امدادات السد وهذه يسمي مشكله
وايضا رئيس نيجيريا
لم يتم الموافقه عليه على انه رئيس لانه
هنالك شكوك حول انتخابه بالتالي هنالك
مساله
تنقل التدخل القوات في
شكرا لك ادم
من دوسلدو في المانيا وهو مدير الاتصال
السابق في المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا
وهي التي منحت قاده الانقلاب مهله كما قلت
تنتهي في وقت قريب هذه الليله وقال عضو
المجلس العسكري في النيجر اللواء محمد
تنبع ان بلاده ستنجح في افشاله خطط ما
وصفها بالقوه الظلاميه في داخل البلاد
وخارجها واضاف تمبا في كلمه امام انصار
المجلس العسكري الذين احتشدوا في العاصمه
اليامي ان قاده الجيش لن يتراجع وعما
سماها بمطالب الشعب
القوه الظلاميه المعاديه لمسيره النيجر
التقدميه والتنويريه اجتمعوا في الخفائن
التخطيط ونحن حتى هذه اللحظه نعلم بخططهم
الاستغلاليه وسنحبطها معا
[موسيقى]
قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه ان مناطق عده
تعرضت لضربات صاروخيه روسيه برا وبحرا
وبالمسيرات اعلنت اسقاط عدد كبير منها
تصعيد ياتي في ظل محاولات الاوكرانيه
للتقدم فيباخ متوازيبولوجيا بل واستهداف
بمسيره لمنطقه موسكو واخر واخر بالصواريخ
الجسر في شبه جزيره القرم يربطها بخيريسون
بينما قال الرئيس الاوكراني
ان هجمات روسيا الاخيره لن تقدم لها شيئا
الليل لم يكن هادئا على اكثر من جبهه في
اوكرانيا القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه حدثت
عن توجيه القوات الروسيه نحو 70 ضربه
بصواريخ من الجو والبحر وبمسيرات خلال
الليل كان من بين الاهداف وفق الرئيس
الاوكراني مصنع لمحركات الطائرات في
مقاطعه زابولوجيا جنوب الشرقي البلاد
واهداف غربيه اوكرانيا لكن في بخموت تبدو
محاوله التقدم الاوكراني متواصله حيث نشر
الجيش الروسي مقاطع فيديو قال انها
الاستهداف مواقع اوكرانيه بالقرب من
بيرخوفا ما ادى الى تراجعها وتدمير دبابات
وعربات مدرعه لكن رئيس الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه قال انهم يتقدمون في
بخموت اسرع من تقدمهم جنوبا بسبب بناء
القوات الروسيه مواقع دفاعيه كامله
التجهيز بشكل عام تحدثت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن شن قواتها هجمات باسلحه جويه
وبحريه بعيده المدى وعاليه الدقه على
مواقع عسكريه اوكرانيه من قواعد الجويه في
غربيه اوكرانيا بينما جاء اعلان كييف عن
اسقاطها نحو 30 صاروخا وسبعه وعشرين مسيره
روسيه وفي مقاطعه قال الجيش الروسي انه
احبطه هجوما كانت القوات الاوكرانيه تحضر
لشنه باتجاه رابوتينا واعلنت الدفاع
الروسيه احباط مواصفاتها محاوله من نظام
كييف لتنفيذ مسمته هجوما ارهابيا بطائره
مسيره على اهداف في منطقه موسكو لكن
اللافته كان ما اعلنته وكاله ريانوفسكي عن
سلطات القرم المواليه لروسيا عن تعرض
جيسري تشونهار لضربه ب 12 صاروخا وتم
اسقاط تسعه منها والجسر الطريق امداد
رئيسي يربط بين خرسون وشبه جزيره القرم
وتسبب قصفه في تضرر خط انابيب الغاز الذي
يمر بالقرب منه وضمن مؤشرات التصعيد اعلن
حاكم العثور على رغم بحري على بعد 100 متر
من شاطئ لوبين بوفو في شبه جزيره
عن السلطات المواليه لروسيا قولها ان
القوات الاوكرانيه استخدمت ذخائر عنقوديه
في قصف مبنى جامعي في المدينه في حين نشر
الرئيس الاوكراني صوره لمركز لنقل الدم في
بلده كوبيانس شرقيه استهدف وفقه بقنبله
روسيه
الاخيره لن تقدم لروسيا شيئا وفق تعبيره
استهدف هجوم صاروخي روسي اخر بلدنا اليوم
استخدمت فيه صواريخ لضرب مصنع
اسقطنا بعض الصواريخ بفضل جنود الدفاع
الجوي لكن بغض النظر عن عدد الهجمات
الروسيه فانها لن تقدم للعدو شيئا حرب
اخرى هذه المره على الجبهات الالكترونيه
عبر الطائره المسيره وهذا ما نقلته صحيفه
واشنطن بوست عن عمل واحده من القوات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه تسمى الفا وتوجيهها
الطائرات بدون طيار لضرب اهداف روسيه مع
تعطل قدره الروس على التشويش عليها سلاح
تبدو اهميته كبيره للاوكرانيين في ظل
الدفاعات الروسيه المحصله التي تعطل سير
هجومهم المضاد
هذا ونقله مجله نيوزويك عن محللين وخبراء
عسكريين ان تكتيكات حلف النيتو التي
يستخدمها الجيش الاوكراني فشلت بسبب عدم
هيمنته على الاجواء واوضح الخبراء
العسكريون ان غياب التفوق الجوي اضطر
الاوكرانيين لاعاده النظر في خططهم
لاقتحام الدفاعات الروسيه واضافوا ان
القوات النيتو القوات النيتو لم يسبق لها
ان اختبرت ما يعانيه الاوكرانيون في
القتال القريب بدون غطاء جوي وكشف
المحللون والخبراء العسكريون ان
الاوكرانيين تخلوا عن بعض التدريبات
والتكتيكات الغربيه وتكيفوا بناء على
تجربتهم تحت النيران
ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده العميد
نبدا بما نقلته عن محللين وخبراء عسكريين
بان الاوكرانيين غيروا تكتيكاتهم لغياب
الغطاء الجوي
اهميه هذا الغطاء وليست هناك خبره كافيه
لدى النيتو لمعرفه ذلك قبل ان يخوضوا
بتكتيكات يضطر الاوكرانيون
لتغييرها في تكييف تكيفهم مع المعركه
عثمان منذ ان بدات الحرب هناك عمليه
التكيف يعني في كل مرحله من المراحل هناك
عمليه تكيف اليوم العقيده وكيف يقاتل
النيتو امر مختلف تماما هو قتال مشترك لكل
الاسلحه دبابات هندسه طيران دفاعات جويه
مدفعيه وما شابه هذا الامر يتطلب تراكمات
من الخبرات الكثيره اليوم عندما نتحدث عن
سته اسابيع فقط للتدريب مع قتال المشترك
هذا الامر ليس بالامر السهل مع دفاع كما
الدفاعات الروسيه بالاضافه الى هذا الامر
العقيده النيتو او طريقه قتالاته تستلزم
الحمايه الجويه
كامر اساسي للنجاح من هنا ما صادفته
القوات الاوكرانيه هي عمليه تاقلم من هنا
عثمان بدانا نرى التغيير في التكتيك
العوده الى المنع والحرمان القصف العمق
الجسور
ات البحريه المسيرات فوقها فوق فوق موسكو
انتقلنا الى مرحله اعداد
للهجوم الذي قد ينجح في المستقبل او قد لا
ينجح عثمان
ويعني
ماذا يمكننا ان نقول انها
استراتيجيه كل طرف في هذه المرحله
في هذه المرحله يجب على الاوكرانيين ان
يحققوا نجاح ما الاهداف كبيره الوسائل
المتواضعه مقابله والدفاعات جويه منها وهي
تتكل على دعم الغرب لنجاح الاستراتيجيه
اليوم حسب ما يبدو ان الجيش الروسي ياخذ
الموقع الدفاعي بالكامل وبالتالي العمل
على ضرب كل امكانيات اوكرانيا لافشال هذا
الهجوم
البري او الهجوم العكسي من هنا اليوم
شاهدنا قصف قواعد جويه القواعد التي
تستعمل للطيران اسيوط التي تستعمل او
الاسكالب والتي تستهدف الجسور في شبه
جزيره القرم الى اي مدى تستطيع اوكرانيا
النقل المعركه الى داخل الاراضي الروسيه
والمناطق التي تحتلها روسيا مثل شبه جزيره
القرم وكيف يمكن ان يؤثر ذلك على مسار
المعركه بالنسبه لروسيا
هذا الامر متعلق بالامكانيات يعني عندما
نتحدث عن
الهاي مارس 80 كم نتحدث عن ستورم شادو 250
كيلومتر نتحدث عن
الذي تطلبه اوكرانيا 300 كيلومتر كل هذا
الامر له علاقه بالامكانيات لمنع
اللوجستيه من هنا استهداف
يعني جسر الكرش استهداف البحريه من هنا
استهداف الجسور شنهار اليوم وهو جسر مهم
جدا عمليه حرمان القوات الروسيه التي
تقاتل في اقليم زفروجيا وخرسون من اي دعم
لوجستي مهم وهي بدات تنجح في هذا الامر
من بيروت الخبير العسكري العميد الياس حنا
شكرا جزيلا لك
اتفق المشاركون في هذه الاستثناء في
اجتماع جده في السعوديه مشان اوكرانيا على
اهميه مواصله التشاور الدولي وتبادل
الاراء بما يسهم في بناء ارضيه مشتركه
تمهد الطريقه للسلام في اوكرانيا واكد
المشاركون في الاجتماع الذين يمثلون اكثر
من 40 دوله ومنظمه دوليه بما في ذلك الامم
المتحده اكدوا اهميه الاستفاده من الاراء
والمقترحات الايجابيه التي بحثت في هذا
الاجتماع
[موسيقى]
في السودان قال مراسل الجزيره ان سلاح
الجوشن نغارات على مواقع للدعم السريع في
الخرطوم بحري وتصاعدت اعمده الدخان الكثيف
جنوبي المدينه وكان مصدر عسكري في الجيش
السوداني قال للجزيره ان سلاح الطيران نفذ
ثغرات جويه ايضا على مواقع للدعم السريع
في محيط الاحياء القريبه من سلاح المدرعات
في الخرطوم كما قصفت الطائرات الحربيه
القصر الجمهوريه التي تسيطر عليه قوات
الدعم السريع وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وكانت
مصادر محليه ذكرت للجزيره ان مواقع للدعم
السريع في الخرطوم تعرضت لقصف مدفعي من
الجيش
وكان الجيش السوداني قد قال انه احرز
تقدما في عدد من مواقع ارتكاز الدعم
السريع وكبدها خسائر بشريه وماديه خلال
اشتباكات امس في حين نفت قوات الدعم
السريع ذلك وقالت انها ما تزال تحاصر
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني في مبنى
المخابرات في الخرطوم
قالت المنظمه الدوليه للهجره الى الصراع
الدائره في السودان خلف اربعه ملايين نازح
ولاجئ واضافت في منشور على موقع اكس ان
المنظمه تراقب الوضع في السودان عن كثب
وتواصل وتوسيع قدراتها التشغيليه في جميع
انحائه
موقع اكس طبعا تويتر سابقا قبل ان يغير
ايلون ماسك هذا الاسم بشكل رسمي الى ليبيا
حيث فاز محمد تكاله برئاسه المجلس الاعلى
للدوله بعد حصوله في الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات على 67 صوتا مقابل 62 صوتا
للرئيس السابق للمجلس خالد المشري كما فاز
سعود عبيد بمنصب النائب الاول لرئيس
المجلس بعد حصوله على 64 صوتا مقابل 58
لناجي مختار النائب الاول السابق لرئيس
المجلس في حين نادى خالد العبادي منصب
النائب الثاني بعد حصوله على 86 صوتا في
الجوله الثانيه بالانتخابات مكتب رئاسه
المجلس امام العضو محمد معذب الذي حصل على
38 صوتا
[موسيقى]
قالت الفلبين الى جنودا الصينيين اعتدوا
على سفر تابعه لقواتها المسلحه كانت في
مهمه روتينيه واضافت مانيلا ان الصينيين
استخدموا خراطيم المياه لمضايقه جنودها
الذين كانوا داخل مياهها الاقليميه في بحر
جنوب الصين
لم يعودوا امنين هنا كانوا في مهمه
الروتينيه لكن الجنود الصينيين ضايقوهم في
انتهاك للقرن الدولي تقوله من الله الناطق
باسم خفر السواحل الصيني قال ان سياده
بلاده على هذه المناطق ليست محل جدال وان
على الفلبين التوقف عن تطفلها في تلك
المياه
واشنطن دخلت على الخط فورا معلنه في بيان
لخارجيتها انها تقف مع الفلبين في مواجهات
التحركات الصينيه الخطره
لا تملوا الصين من استعراض قوتها هنا لكن
مطالبها بالسياده على الممر المائي لا
يسندها القانون الدولي حيث تطالب كل من
ماليزيا وفيتنام بروناي وتايوان والفلبين
بسياده على مناطق محدده من الممر المائي
الاستراتيجي فما داخل مرور البضائع سنويا
من هنا تقدر بتريليونات الدولارات
في عام 2016 صدر حكم من محكمه التحكيم
الدولي
بان لا اساس للادعاءات الصينيه اطلاقا
بيجين تجاهلت الحكم واقامت قواعد عسكريه
على مناطق غنيه بالشعاب المرجانيه تدعيها
الفلبين تزداد حساسيه بيجين باضطراد مع
ازدياد قوتها فبحر جنوب الصين بالنسبه لها
لم يعد ممرا مائيا عاديا كما كان بل اصبح
مياها اقليميه لقوه عظمى هي الصين الجديد
الصين التي ترى في الدعاه الفلبين
وحلفائها الغربيين تذكارا بايام ضعفها
واستسلامها للقوى الغربيه وهي ايام
وذكريات لا تفوت الصين فرصه للتذكير بانها
جزء من الماضي
طبول الحرب النوويه تدق مره اخرى هذا ما
حذر منه الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو بوتيريش في الذكرى الثامنه
والسبعين للقصف الامريكي لمدينه هيروشيما
اليابانيه بالقنبله الذريه فما الذي حدث
ولماذا حين اندلعت الحرب العالميه الثانيه
كان عدد سكان هيروشيما يقدر باكثر من 340
الف نسمه وكانت المدينه تعتبر اهم المراكز
الصناعيه والعسكريه وثانيه الحواضر
اليابانيه الكبرى وتوجد فيها اهم القواعد
العسكريه والجزء الاهم من القاعده
الصناعيه العسكريه بالبلاد مع تقهقر
اليابان امام قوات الحلفاء اصبحت هيروشيما
قاعده
ارتكاذها الاهم في دفاعها عن سيادتها وعن
حوزتها الترابيه امام تقدم الحلفاء فنقلت
اليها قياده الجيش وتم تركيز القوات
الجويه
الدفاع الصاروخي حولها وفي ضوء هذه
المعطيات وقع اختيار القاده العسكريه
الخدر العسكريه الامريكيه وقع اختيارهم
على هيروشيما لتكون هدف اول قنبله ذريه
تستخدمها لحسم الحرب في السادس من اغسطس
عام
القت القاذفه الامريكيه
القنبله الذريه الطفل البديل القتها على
هيروشيما تسبب ذلك في دمار كلي في دائره
النصف قطرها قطرها كيلومتر
و600 متر كما دمر اكثر من 70% من مباني
المدينه جراء الانفجار النووي
قتل الالاف في الحال ونحو 140 الفا اخرين
بحلول نهايه العام واستسلمت اليابان في
الخامس عشر من اغسطس بطبيعه الحال خضعت
المدينه لبرنامج شامل لاعاده الاعمار
مكنها من استعاده مكانتها لكنه لم ينجح في
ازاله اثار التلوث النووي الذي لا تزال
اثاره باثره في شكل تشوهات خلقيه
بالمواليد وتسمم الاشعاعي للغطاء النباتي
والمياه الجوفيه لكن ما خصوصيه ذكرى
هيروشيما هذه المره
قبل ساعات
الامير العام للامم المتحده بتلويح بعض
الدول بالتهديد النووي مهدده باستخدام
اداه الاباده هذه وقال ان طبول الحرب
النوويه تقرع تقرع من جديد رئيس الوزراء
الياباني فوميوم في الشتاء اشاره صراحه
الى ما سماها تهديدات روسيا النوويه غير
المقبوله وقال الى الدمار الذي احدثته
الاسلحه النوويه في هيروشيما لا يمكن ان
يتكرر ابدا وفي دعوه مشتركه نادره من
نوعها طالبه اكثر من 100 مجله طبيه عالميه
بارزه بتحرك عاجل للتخلص من الاسلحه
النوويه محذره من ان خطر وقوع كانت
النوويه كبير ويتفاقم عن الاثار المحتمله
يقول كريس بيلينسكي من الجمعيه العالميه
للمحررين المتخصصين في المجال الطبي انه
حتى اذا اندلعت حرب نوويه محدوده تستخدم
فيها 250 فقط من الاسلحه النوويه في
العالم عددها 13 الفا فيمكن ان يتسبب
الامر في مقتل 120 مليون شخص فورا هذا
الاحتمال المخيف
يمكن ان يتسبب ايضا في اضطراب المناخ في
العالم ما يؤدي الى مجاعه ناجمه عن
استخدام سلاح النووي ويشكل خطرا على
مليوني شخص وذلك بناء بناء على ابحاث
سابقه ينضم الينا من مدينه او مدينه
ارساله في السويد الدكتور جرجري وهو باحث
المتخصص في دراسات السلامه والنزاع
الدكتور جريجري بعد نحو 80 عاما من القاء
القنبله الذريه الامريكيه على نجازاكي
وهيروشيما يتحدث الامين العام للامم
المتحده عن ان طبول الحرب النوويه تقرع هل
بالفعل توجد شواهد على ان هذا احتمال
حقيقي قائم في هذا الوقت
هنالك احتماليه ربما احتماليه بعيده لكنها
لا يجب استبعادها لان لدينا تصعيد ومواجهه
في الصراعات بين
القوه الغربيه الكبرى وهي الولايات
المتحده والقوات غير الغربيه مثل روسيا
والصين وهي في صعود الان بالتالي لا يجب
ان نغض النظر بشكل تماما حتى ولو كان هذا
الاحتمال بعيدا
الى اي مدى هو بعيد يعني عندما نتحدث عن
هيروشيما كانت هناك حرب عالميه في ذلك
الوقت هل الاجواء التي نعيشها الان قريبه
باي حال من الاحوال من تلك الاجواء في عام
هذه المرحله كلا
كان هنالك
في الحرب الحرب كان هنالك في حسابات
الولايات المتحده ان تلقي القنبله على
هيروشيما من اجل
ان
توقف
توقيف خساره الارواح بين القوات الامريكيه
القوه القنبله الثانيه كانت لم تكن ضد
الياباني اذا كانت لتحذير الاتحاد
السوفيتي وتم تقرير اتخاذ هذا القرار بعد
استسلام اليابان وكان هذا الامر في نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه اذا مانع ننظر الى
الوضع الان لدينا مقاربتان مختلفتان لهذه
العقيده النوويه لدينا روسيا والتي
تقوم باتخاذ اجراءات انتقاميه او تهدد
باتخاذ اجراءات الانتقاليه الولايات
المتحده ما لديه تحتفظ بامكانيه
الضربه الاولى
ولكنها هي ربما قد يكون هذا كل هذه الامور
قد تكون تصريحات غبيه وقصيره النظر اذا
نظرنا الى التاريخ ونظرنا الى حجم الدمار
يقولون ان حتى حرب نوويه محدوده يمكن ان
تقضي على 120 مليون شخص فورا ورئيس
الوزراء الياباني يقول انما حدث فيه روسيا
ما كان مرعبا للغايه بحيث لا يجب ان يلوح
احد بحرب نوويه هل يمكن ان يقع العالم في
هذا الفخ مره اخرى رغم كل الاثار الكارثيه
انا اوافق مع هذه المقوله من الغباء
التحدث عن حرب نوويه محدوده من هو ما هو
المحدد اذا ما بدانا بشيء هل هنالك اي
ضماد انها سيتوقف عند مرحله معينه كلا لن
يحصل ذلك
كانهم نفتح بؤره للمشاكل ومن الصعب تحديد
والسيطره على نتائجها بالتالي لا يجب
علينا ان نتحاشى ان نخوض في هذا الامر منذ
بدايته شكرا جزيلا لك من مدينه ابو سلا في
السويد الدكتور جريجري سايمنز
بلنس الباحث المختص في دراسات السلام
والنزاعات شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
صور مذهله وتفاصيل وغير مسبوقه نتحدث عن
رصد العلماء بواسطه تلسكوب الفضائي
المراحل الاخيره من حياه نجم يبعد عن
الارض نحو 1600 سنه ضوئيه تكشف هذه
اللقطات هيكلا على شكل كعكه من الغاز
المتوهج يسمى سديم الحلقه وهو جسم معروف
في السماء
وتشكل السديم عندما فجر نجم يحتضر كثيرا
من مادته في الفضاء ماده الى انتاج حلقات
ملونه زاهيه وفقاعات متوسعه وغيوم معقده
وناعمه ويعتقد العلماء ان هذا هو مصير
الشمس بعد مليارات السنين من الاهل
الصور الجديده المذهله التي التقطها
تلسكوب جيمس ويب توفر فرصه لا مثيل لها
لدراسه وفهم العمليات المعقده التي شكلت
هذه التحفه الكونيه هي تذكرنا ايضا بعظمه
الكون وابداع الخالق والاسرار التي لا
تنتهي ولا يسعنا بعد تلمس خيوطها الا ان
نقول سبحان الله
دمتم بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]